twenty thousand years hundreds of
centuries countless generations of
evolution and nurture to take the mighty
wolf and turn him into the even mightier
[Music]
alpha as rat puppy in the thumbnail
don't hate the player hate the game so
alpha is the true story not really true
at all they very made-up story this
essentially shows the domestication of
dogs twenty thousand years ago or twenty
thousand BC don't remember which one is
said this being the internet that's
probably gonna be a very important bit
of information that's gonna be corrected
in comment section what is a long time
ago in a galaxy not so far far away
because it's this world in this galaxy
this tribe of early man goes hunting and
the young dude who's the son of the
chief he falls over a cliff he gets hurt
they think he's dead but he lives and he
needs to get home and on his way home he
runs across a wolf who gets wounded so
they're both wounded and they stick
together thus the domestication of dogs
has begun or wolves this is pretty much
the revenant if the revenant had a wolf
but it was essentially a hallmark movie
but you know the pitch for this was like
it's the revenant with the wolf that's
so metal bunny because this is direct
about one of the Hughes brothers of like
the Hughes brothers but there's only one
of the Hughes brothers so it's directed
by a Hughes brother you see some of that
talent in here some of the
cinematography you're like well that
looks amazing landscapes look lush they
feel fleshed out alive and they feel
very I was gonna say foreign but it's
it's earth feels very uninhabited it's
what I'm trying to say they did a good
job at making the world feel untouched
like it was 20,000 years ago some time
to look convincing sometimes you're like
that is a green screen but wouldn't it
look convincing I was really impressed
also the relationship between the dog
because I mean I'm a dog lover but as a
dog lover I thought it was sweet seeing
the connection between the human and the
dog form or the wolf it was really
jarring how this wolf essentially went
from being a wolf to being a dog whereas
those steps must have taken generations
in this movie it's like dying it's a dog
now some a it's out there or kids too
aren't idiots just kids and hope people
don't get the idea like let's go pet a
wolf if I say no watch the gray after
watching this it's a better
representation of what's gonna happen if
you go pet a wolf but although I felt
that connection was sweet
that's really all the movie has it's
movies an escort mission essentially or
a less interesting version of Metal Gear
Solid 5 you've picked diamond dog really
is a lot of walking sitting interacting
with the wolf or walking sitting
interacting with the wolf dog walking
sitting interacting with the dog I don't
know what else it would have been
when the engagement was kind of fleeting
there really shows how engaging the
revenant was this movie on more than a
few occasions I was like I'm ready to go
I love this movies only I feel like it
was just over an hour and a half long
and we're my usual complaint for a movie
as of late for the pacing and the timing
is the last act felt a little too
drawn-out I felt like the last act of
this movie was a bit too chopped up
something dramatic happens but the drama
really doesn't marinate that much oh
that's intense it's okay we're over it
by the next thing and then the movie
ends just chopped out chop I feel like
the last act of this movie was filmed
and supposed to be another half an hour
long and they just sliced it down you
walk out of this movie like it was sweet
and it was cute to see that you know dog
connection but really it is a hallmark
movie it's like a made-for-tv movie that
somehow got a budget safe for families
for the most part but I feel like if
it's safe for families kids have other
things they'll want to watch like I'd
say for families by the way kids you're
gonna have to read subtitles through the
entire thing which completely makes
sense they wouldn't speak English I
wouldn't really speak any language we
know on the other hand I don't want to
be the one to look to a kid and be like
by the way reading subtitles passion of
the christ' style if I were a kid I'd be
like nope what Avengers movie we
watching today Infinity Ward just came
out of blu-ray
let's just watch that in the end I'm
pushing the dog lover part of me aside
the cat lover is gonna come out and say
I'm just not gonna remember this in
t-minus one day yeah I've already forgot
funny now that we have made a movie
about how we domesticated dogs do you
think cats are gonna make a movie about
how they domesticated people imagine
cats could get it done they didn't keep
knocking the cameras at the table
sleeping on the keyboards as they're
editing the videos guess it'll never
happen
alright so alpha have you seen it why
did you think about it or what's a movie
you saw in theaters and you were like
that's a hallmark movie that's a
made-for-tv movie don't you try to dress
it up with a budgets what it is whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you
[Music]